salut tout le monde moi c'est flou
l'artiste de la vie
là je vois des
je loue la en mode le type dispard
il a l'habitude d'être en retard non
c'est pas ça et il n'y a pas que moi
dans le milieu du cinéma
on nous appelle parfois nous autre
spécialiste en effets spéciaux les
artistes de l'invisible alors pourquoi
et bien parce que si notre travail est
bien fait dennis voit pas alors c'est
clair que quand on inclut ce des gros
monstres partout et l'image ça se voit
et clairement c'est le but mais c'est le
trucage et de qualité alors le
spectateur ne passe pas son temps à le
dire nous tiens godzilla pikachu on les
a ajouté la non ils sont là ils prennent
part à l'histoire et font leur vie de
monstres ou de pokémon dans le milieu on
appelle ça une intégration d'image de
synthèse
alors comment ça marche pour réaliser
une bonne intégration d'image de
synthèse et bien je dirais qu'il ya deux
choses dans un premier temps il y a la
technique et le savoir-faire que
j'inscrirai dans un processus créatif et
puis de l'autre côté il ya l'expérience
alors bien sûr il ya aussi d'autres
facteurs mais aujourd'hui j'aimerais
parler d'eux avec voûte de mon processus
créatif et aussi et surtout vous dire ce
que ça représente pour moi aujourd'hui
avoir de l'expérience
alors au début je pensais que pour
réaliser cette alchimie qui permet
d'intégrer des monstres des images de
synthèse dans une image réelle
il suffisait d'attraper le gros guide
des effets spéciaux j'ouvre mon logiciel
clic clic
et puis alors samedi page 45 les gros
monstres pour une bonne intégration
suivez les étapes suivantes
je pensais aussi que l'expérience était
quantifiable au nombre de trucs et
astuces que tu connaissais que tu avais
dans ta boîte à outils mais en fait ça
marche pas vraiment comme ça alors bien
sûr on a des techniques établies qui ont
fait leurs preuves avec le temps on sait
par exemple retirer des fonds vers des
fonds bleus on est capable de créer des
images de synthèse réaliste avec une
animation plausible on suit au mieux les
règles de la physique pour créer des
explosions des fluides malgré tout ça à
chaque nouveau film on a toujours des
nouveaux problèmes
bah ouais fallait que ça arrive tu vois
alors je voulais vous dire quand même
que j'étais pas tout seul à la
réalisation d'un effet spécial on était
des grosses équipes qui étaient
regroupés en plusieurs spécialités
alors il ya ceux qui modèlent ce qui
anime ce qui simule ce qui est clair ce
qui peignent et j'en passe pour réaliser
un plan c des grosses équipes organisée
et hiérarchisée
moi j'ai pour spécialité ce qu'on
appelle le compositing le compositing
c'est l'art d'assembler les différentes
couches des faits j'ai à ma disposition
les images filmées par la caméra je vais
retirer les fonds vers les ponts les
fonds bleu s'il y en a et puis je vais
intégrer les faux décors les effets les
créatures corps ont éclairé et animée
mes collègues et puis aussi je vais
ajouter des éléments venant de vidéos de
photos de décors peints bref c'est un
peu de la bidouille des fois quand même
mais j'ai la responsabilité d
intégration des images de synthèse et ça
parfois c'est une grosse responsabilité
alors je pourrais dire que mon travail
se scinde en deux parties
il ya cette première partie où je
découvre les éléments mis à ma
disposition
alors je vais commencer à les composés
entre elles et puis je vais voir ce que
je peux faire avec
alors cherche pas encore à rendre les
choses réelles réaliste à ce moment là
je cherche plutôt à créer une esquisse
quelque chose qui va me donner la
direction dans laquelle je vais aller le
rythme
le storytelling la composition du plan
alors tout ça c'est marrant parce que ça
me fait penser à quand j'étais gamin à
noël et que j'attendais une nouvelle
boîte de lego sur le sous le sapin
je courais encore en pyjama tu sais j'en
ai trop bien des lego j'adorais ça voilà
c'est la même chose
j'ai un certain nombre de pièces et puis
je vais créer un univers fantastique
avec des fois je mets mots au boulot et
en pyjama
alors ensuite il ya la deuxième partie
du travail celle qui consiste à intégrer
tous ces éléments ensemble les rendre
réel leur donner vie et alors avant de
vous expliquer un peu plus comment
comment on fait comment moi je perds
j'aimerais qu'on marque une pause et
qu'on regarde que chacun observe autour
de soi
qu'est ce qui rend notre univers
visuellement réelle alors uniquement à
l'aide de vos yeux c'est pas facile
alors par exemple vous voyez là sur
scène devant vous quels sont les
éléments qu'on peut prendre en compte
alors il ya la lumière qui éclaire de
façon à ce qu'elles éclairent de le
décor de la même façon il ya là la
couleur la chaleur de cette lumière sa
direction et puis les ombres qu'elle
génère et puis après il ya moi alors il
ya là il ya la texture de mes vêtements
la texture de ma peau
l'imperfection de la nature et puis il
ya les détails la perspective
par exemple ceux qui sont assis au
dernier rang ne perçoivent pas du tout
la même façon que ceux qui sont assis au
premier rang ici au premier rang je sais
que vous êtes capable de voir les poils
que mon chat abribus m'a laissé sur mon
t-shirt alors que vous dernier rang vous
avez peut-être même pas remarqué que
j'étais mal rasé vous dire en fait que à
l'époque j'ai filé une photo à
l'organisation et j'ai essayé de de
ressembler au type que j'avais envoyé la
photo parce que j'avais quand même une
sacrée tâche mais bon bref
ah la la
alors tous ces détails au poil près
permettent à notre cerveau d'en conclure
que cet instant est réel car il a il
peut faire référence à d'autres
événements similaires qu'il a déjà vécu
alors pour qu'un trucage marche il faut
appliquer ces mêmes règles il faut tirer
ses règles du réel les applique à lire
et à la fin que le spectateur le
spectateur se dise ah ben oui vous somme
marche c'est comme dans la vraie vie et
il en va de même avec les créatures
fantastiques et les mondes fantastiques
aussi
il est important de tirer ses
observations du réel
même si nous n'avons jamais vu le chat
potté où les mignonnes ce au delà de la
direction artistique du film
il faut tirer nos observations du réel
et les applique à l'irréel afin de créer
cette métaphore sensorielle afin que le
cerveau du spectateur acceptent de
coopérer avec les images alors quelles
sont ces éléments d'observation
est ce que c'est la lumière est ce que
c'est le point on a encore un sens j'ai
pas de réponse toute faite à chaque
nouveau plan à chaque nouveau film on a
dû de nouvelles problématiques parfois
facile parfois difficile
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à chaque fois je
dois expérimenté tenter une nouvelle
approche et parfois ça fonctionne
parfois banon alors j'aimerais vous
donner un exemple concret en 2013 je
travaillais sur godzilla et nous avions
des consignes de direction artistique
très précise alors par exemple il
fallait représenter au mieux la notion
de taille du monstre et bien grand globe
c'est pas nouveau il devait de
gigantesques le plus grand qu'un gratte
ciel est alors pour ça la direction
artistique qu'on avait c'était que
godzilla et végétaux jamais apparaître
en entier à l'image
il était toujours à moitié caché par des
building n'est pas loin de sortir le
truc ou alors submergée par de l'eau ou
alors derrière des couches de brouillard
est brume ce qui m'amène à une deuxième
direction artistique importante c'était
la présence d'énormément de pluie de
fumée de feux de brouillard et alors
tous ces éléments devaient se mélanger
pour mettre en valeur les créatures et
renforcer l'aspect chaotique et mystique
du film alors ça voulait dire aussi
qu'il y avait une tonne d'éléments
intégré que ça c'était super dur et que
mais bon il fallait vraiment qu'on
arrive à intégrer tous ces éléments pour
que le spectateur se dise je sais bien
que godzilla n'existe pas mais mais là
j'y crois j'ai même pas besoin du petit
verre de gnôle c'est bon
alors je vais être franc avec vous sur
ce film j'ai vraiment galéré
c'était super dur et je me souviendrai
toujours du temps qu'il m'a fallu pour
comprendre comment représenter cette
impression de distance et de profondeur
à travers différents éléments de brume
de brouillard de feu etc
j'avais mon esquisse j'avais réussi à
superposer tous les éléments mais je
n'arrivais pas à leur donner vie
tout était là mais ça marchait pas alors
javel est bien sûr de mes superviseurs
et de mes collègues qui me donner leur
avis et qui me permet d'avancer par apa
mais malgré tout l'intégration était
bien trop visibles ça marchait pas un
soir je suis sorti du bureau assez tard
après un énième refus de mon travail par
ma supervision
il était passé minuit alors où est des
fois travaillé dans les effets spéciaux
c'est aussi être invisible pour sa
famille et ses amis
en période de fin de projet et bref
alors je suis sorti du studio à minuit
puis j'ai enfourché mon vélo pour
rentrer chez moi et alors je l'aimais
bien faire du vélo à ce moment de
l'année à vancouver au canada
c'était c'était l'automne et juste avant
l'hiver
il ya beaucoup il ya cette espèce de
brume épaisse qui ceux qui se forment
dans les rues et ça donne un aspect très
étrange alors la brume dans les rues ça
n'a rien à voir avec le fait qu'ils
viennent de légaliser le cannabis au
canada
d'accord c'est purement météorologiques
alors je [ __ ] est à fond parce que
j'avais vite envie d'aller me coucher il
était tard mais aussi parce que j'avais
besoin d'évacuer ma frustration
franchement quand tu fais des plans et
des plans et des plans et des versions
et des itérations de la même chose sans
jamais aucun succès ça devient
extrêmement frustrant et je commençais
vraiment on se commence à se remettre en
question est-ce que je suis fait pour ce
métier
cette nuit là je me suis vraiment je me
suis fait râler contre moi je relaie
dans la rue les gens me jugent ajouté
qu'un nul change de métier et à aucun
talent tu ferais mieux de faire un truc
plus calmes genre gérer un petit airbnb
sur la plage au rockhal voix bref
j'étais sur le pont durable pour ceux
qui connaissent qui aurait été à
vancouver et j'avais laissé derrière moi
le centre ville
et je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
oublié d'allumer les lumières de mon
vélo
alors au delà du fait que c'est une
prune assez élevé au canada
c'était aussi pas forcément très safe
très bref a vu la visibilité
bref donc du coup je me suis arrêté sur
sur le côté et puis pour pour allumer
les lumières
j'ai tourné la tête et là j'ai vu au
loin
c'était hallucinant le centre ville
était baigné dans un épais brouillard et
on voyait un les toits des gratte ciel
qui disparaissait dans la brume les
rendant encore plus haut et puis il y
avait les boules et où les lumières de
la ville qui diffusait des à l'eau
colorée dans le brouillard et puis il y
avait cette usine devant moi qui
crachait une grosse fumée blanche et
pesc absorber les lumières des néons et
qu'il lirait qu'il est rediffusé on
pouvait sentir la profondeur dans
l'atmosphère on pouvait pour sentir la
profondeur dans le brouillard et puis
seulement certains détails apparaissent
et par ci par là j'étais là halluciné le
gt dans le film c'est à dire qu'à ce
moment précis la vie réelle suivait la
même direction artistique que la
séquence du film sur laquelle je
travaillais alors j'ai observé tout ce
que je pouvais je voulais vraiment pas
en manquer un morceau de des subtiles
variations la couleur du ciel aux
infimes particules de brume devant moi
c'était 7 et magique c'était comme si
mon sens de la vue était décuplée
je percevais à ce moment là quelque
chose qui avait toujours été invisible
pour moi et puis ce soir là eh bien je
trouver la solution à mon problème
le lendemain je suis arrivé au bureau
puis en quelques heures j'ai fait les
modifications apportées à mon plan est
mon travail a été apprise approuvé par
mes superviseur monde dur labeur et est
devenu invisible
alors j'ai envie de vous montrer
quelques-uns de ses plans que j'ai
réalisé à ce moment là j'ai pas mis de
son parce qu'on est sur le visuel et je
vous rejoins juste après
alors c'était certains me diront bah
ouais mon pote suffisait de regarder tu
vois alors certes certes la réalité
m'avait aidé à réaliser mon trucage mais
c'est avant tout la persévérance et
l'exploration de l'image qui m'ont aidé
à être plus curieux plus sensibles au
monde qui m'entoure
alors cette histoire que je viens de
vous raconter c'est pas un cas isolé
j'ai vécu plusieurs fois je continue à
la vivre à chaque nouveau film il ya ce
petit truc qui se passe certains
appelleront ça une déformation
professionnelle
moi j'appelle ça mais moment de
clairvoyance geek alors par exemple
quelqu'un sur deadpool de la dernière
fois c'était le feu j'étais obnubilé par
le feu parce que je travaillais sur les
mains enflammée du gamin rusty sur
pokémon c'était je travaillais sur la
fréquence de la forêt dont c'était la
lumière dans la forêt comment elle se
déplaçait par les feuilles
ça affecte ça affecte vraiment quand
j'étais chez dreamworks était tout
autant des créatures poilues donc du
coup c'était les poils encore une fois
et est pour vous dire à quel point ça
affecte la leur ce moment je travaille
sur un crash d'avion
je peux vous dire que prendre l'avion
pour venir ici
c'était en votre jambon j'ai récupéré
quelques bonnes références visuelles ce
c'était bien atteindre ce moment de
clairvoyance qui permet de déceler ce
petit détail qui va transformer un
travail artistique demande du temps
toutes ces itérations ces versions sont
nécessaires elles me permettent de
définir dans un premier temps qu'est ce
qui va être techniquement possible
qu'est ce qui va être artistiquement
possible les versions que je présentais
à mes superviseur n'était pas forcément
déplorable mais elle ne marchait pas
elle ne fonctionnait pas dans un
contexte donné comme le contexte du film
par exemple à chaque refus d'une de mes
versions ça me permettait d'éliminer une
voie sans issue
mais aussi de garder les éléments
importants et puis de fil en aiguille on
arrive à mettre les choses en place afin
de percevoir la solution finale il est
important de mettre de l'ordre dans le
cadeau dans le domaine de l'ordre dans
le chaos initial
et puis alors ben ça y est on peut voir
enfin qu'est-ce qui manque un petit
reflet de réalisme dans les yeux d'un
personnage l'ajustement de certains
éléments qui vont permettre de mieux
retranscrire l'espace ou alors la
colonne correction des couleurs qui vont
permettre une meilleure cohérence
visuelle comme tous ces petits détails
ont été 1 1
ajoutez ajusté alors n'est ce sentiment
d'accomplissement et c'est tout ça le
processus créatif
ed catmull le fondateur de pixar disait
à ce propos faire des erreurs n'est pas
un mal ce n'est pas un mal en soi ce
n'est pas un mal du tout c'est la
conséquence nécessaire à
l'accomplissement de quelque chose de
nouveau alors cette citation à beaucoup
d'importance pour moi parce qu'il m'aura
fallu du temps pour comprendre que mes
erreurs mais échec n'était pas un mal
mais qu'elles étaient nécessaires à ce
processus créatif
il m'aura fallu du temps pour ne plus
avoir honte de tenter et
et d'échouer et juste simplement
d'essayer il m'aura fallu du temps pour
comprendre qu'il fallait du temps il
m'aura fallu du temps pour comprendre
que travailler ça ne voulait pas
toujours dire réussir que le chemin qui
mène à la réussite n'est pas toujours
linéaires j'irai même au delà dire que
travailler ça ne veut pas toujours dire
que l'on sait ce que l'on fait pour moi
l'expérience jeu-là redéfini à chaque
nouveau projet jeu je remuerai improvise
où je jeu redéfini ce processus créatif
je me l'approprié un peu plus et puis je
cherche toujours à aller plus loin
mais pour moi la vraie expérience c'est
l'acceptation de ce processus créatif
inévitable à toute création pour être un
artiste
il m'aura fallu du temps pour me rendre
compte que pour être un artiste mais
invisible il me fallait d'abord déjà
être capable de percevoir l'invisible
alors s'il ya une chose que je peux
tirer de mon expérience
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on
fait plat face à un problème gros comme
godzilla
à chaque fois qu'on échoue il faut pas
renoncer
il faut garder la conviction que toute
étape est nécessaire à l'accomplissement
et que l'on commence seulement à
distinguer l'invisible je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]